hey you guys
time for the flickers of fear show where
i review movies
so this one okay so this is like a
really interesting way that i came
across this one
this movie is called the haunting of
julia commonly i've also seen it called
full circle
i believe it was released as full circle
in the uk but
this movie it seemed like it's it's not
super well known
it came out in the uk in 1977 under the
title full circle as i mentioned
didn't kind of get any traction got some
reviews and [ __ ] like that
most mostly negative which i don't
really get
so it sort of went nowhere and then it
was released in the u.s several years
later in 1981 under the name the
haunting of julia and also didn't really
go anywhere
now i'm not sure like nowadays for a
long time it was only available on vhs
like it didn't even have a
dvd release as far as i know it doesn't
have a blu-ray release
and i think i ended up seeing it sort of
accidentally or randomly just because
someone had uploaded a copy to youtube
and i saw that it was based on the peter
straub novel
julia from 1975 which i read a long time
ago
and i was like well they made an
adaptation of that it's like i didn't
know
so i ended up watching it and i really
really loved it
and i was like what the hell where is
this movie now i don't know
nowadays it might be easier to get
because shutter just added it at least
in the us maybe in the uk too i'm not
really sure
but i was really really excited to see
it and i think that you can rent it on
youtube
and it looks like it's you know in the
really nice widescreen presentation
because i feel like the the free one
that i watched on youtube didn't look
too bad but it looked like it was a rip
from a vhs
so it looked kind of crappy but the one
that's on shutter
right now looks really nice and it's
like wide screen presentation or
anything so i would actually recommend
if you can't get it in physical medium
i'm not sure if you can
but i would actually recommend that you
watch it because i feel like it's sort
of
it's like an underappreciated gem i
think
now that's not to say it's not going to
be for everybody like i said you know
no movie is i suppose but if you're
really into
70s era creepy slow burn
ghost stories haunted house sort of
stories along the lines of the
changeling
or don't look now or burnt offerings or
something like that
then you probably really really dig this
also i want to say rosemary's baby
because
mia farrow is in this and the character
that she plays in this is very much like
uh rosemary woodhouse who she played in
rosemary's baby so if you liked that you
would probably dig this as well although
as i said this is more
a sort of slow burn dramatic ghost story
not so much demonic possession or
anything like that
so the movie uh was actually this is
very funny too the movie was actually
directed by richard lon
crane and he is a british tv and film
director and when i decided to do this
movie because like i said i'd seen it
probably six or seven years ago just
randomly on youtube and then i was
excited to see that shutter had added it
so i wanted to review it because i
really
feel like more people need to see it and
i didn't realize when i was re-watching
it
that richard longrein who directed it is
also the same guy
that directed the film version of
brimstone and treacle the one with
sting that we talked about uh on our
matinee show
not too long ago so i was like well
that's a little weird bit of kismet
there isn't it i didn't even realize
that it was the same director
shows what i know so the movie also
stars uh kier dalia if i'm pronouncing
that right the guy
who probably most famous from 2001 a
space odyssey he's been in various other
things as well
also i realized um the daughter from the
very beginning of the movie she's only
in the first
you know probably five or ten minutes
was played by sophie ward
and i was kind of like man she looks so
familiar and then i realized that she
was actually in young sherlock holmes
which i think came out in 1986
and i saw like a million times back in
cable so i was like oh well that
explains it that's where i've seen her
before
and it also stars tom conte and i think
that he is probably
i mean i really really dug this movie i
thought the atmosphere of it was great
the score is fantastic i love the music
of it
you know because this is exactly my jam
i love this kind of like slow
atmospheric it's a ghost story it's also
like a murder mystery and i'm super
super into that
uh but tom conte is probably like the
best thing about this movie he's like
i don't want to say he's like comic
relief but he's like i don't know he's
kind of like the voice of reason and
he's kind of like a real bright spot in
the movie he plays
uh mia pharaoh's best friend and all
this other kind of [ __ ] and he's like
great in it everybody's great in it but
he's like particularly great so
what is this movie about so mia farrow
plays
a woman named julia lofting now she's
married to
a dude played by kiera delia whose name
is magnus
who you don't see them interact as
husband and wife very much but
even from that brief interaction you can
kind of tell
that not i mean they're very wealthy
and you find out at some point that
she's kind of the one with all the money
i didn't actually even catch that like
the first couple times i watched this
because as it goes on and i was kind of
like well why does her husband want her
back so bad
and then like when the when the uh when
i watched it this time i was kind of
like oh well that explains that she's
the one with all the money
and uh so yeah so you can tell that he's
kind of
a little bit cold a little bit
disinterested maybe
even from the beginning like only
married her for her money perhaps i'm
not really sure
but so the two of them have a daughter
who i believe i
i don't know if she's supposed to be i
think the
the synopsis said she was eight but she
looks a little bit older than that she
actually looks 10 or 11.
so in the first scene which is actually
pretty [ __ ]
horrific to watch their daughter
they're all at uh their breakfast table
this is set in london by the way
where they live kensington i believe it
is
uh so they're all at the breakfast table
and their little girl
chokes on a piece of apple
and i guess um they didn't really know
the uh
heimlich maneuver back then and i did
look it up and i think the heimlich
maneuver wasn't
actually really all that widely known in
the mid
70s which is when the novel came out so
i guess
you know that's that's that so they so
they don't really know the heimlich
maneuver like you know magnus is hanging
her upside down trying to get her out
and like
he's like i gotta call the you know
ambulance and you know
uh julia's like you know we don't have
time and so and the little girl is like
dying like right there on the floor and
like i said it's a horrific horrific
scene i've heard that like if you have
children it's really hard to watch it's
hard for me to watch too and i'm just
like not a big fan of kids
but it's like just the way it's because
you can imagine that happening
like somebody just dying right in front
of you like that and just happening
right
right out of the blue so the little
girl's dying
and finally uh you know julia is like
well you know the ambulance isn't going
to get here in time she has to breathe
so she tries to do an impromptu
tracheotomy on her which doesn't work
and the little girl ends up dying the
little girl's name is katie by the way
now after that understandably
julia has a nervous breakdown and she is
kind of put into a sanatorium or
whatever it is
now she's only in there for two months
which really isn't that long to get over
the death of a kid but
it really does seem like everyone's kind
of like okay you're fine you know go out
in the world or whatever
so her husband comes to pick her up and
again
understandably she doesn't really have
anything she doesn't really want to have
anything more to do with him because
she explains kind of later on she's like
you know it it was bad from the
beginning and it's like now that our
daughter isn't around anymore there's
really no reason for me to stay with him
um you know so i'm just i'm i'm out of
here so magnus goes pick her up and she
just kind of like evades him and like
runs out the back and [ __ ] takes off
in a cab
now since she's the one with all the
money she
is able to purchase a really really nice
house and uh you know all by herself
it's furnished and everything like that
she's like you know i'm just going there
i'm going to start my life over i don't
really want to talk to magnus anymore
now magnus is really and like i said the
first couple times i saw this movie i
was like why is he so he's he is
essentially like starts stalking her
like at first um julia tells
her sister-in-law she's like please
don't tell him where i am
but magnus kind of threatens his
sister-in-law
not threatens or threatens her but kind
of like bullies her into like telling
where julia is and then he starts
calling her and then he just basically
starts harassing her like lurking around
the house like he breaks in at one point
so you know he's kind of a dick bag so
uh so she moves in by herself and like i
said she's got magnus kind of creeping
around
wanting her to uh you know come back to
him
i think it's because he wants to
eventually have her committed and then
he's going to take all her money that's
what i think it's a and
i think it's kind of like implied that
that's what he's gonna do because he
doesn't really seem to give
that much of a [ __ ] about her and he
doesn't really seem all that upset that
their daughter is dead like he's just
kind of
you know so that's kind of my theory and
i'm sticking to it
so basically julia is hanging out with
her friend uh mark who's played by tom
cotti he owns like a
antique shop or whatever so she has this
really cool house
now from the very beginning she begins
to think that maybe
this house might be just a little bit
haunted um
like just weird [ __ ] starts having like
you know she has this heater
in the room and it's just kind of like
it won't go off like even though she
turns it off it keeps turning itself
back on
it's just like various things like that
there's a there's a little toy that she
brings with her that was
her daughter katie's which is like a
little like harlequin clown or whatever
with little symbols
and it does its little symbols by itself
sometimes so it's like she kind of gets
the feeling that maybe her daughter is
still
around or is still haunting her or
whatever now it so happens that magnus
her jackal
ex-husband is so
keen to get her back into his uh
clutches that he engineers
he's like he says to his sister hey you
know that
that uh seance group that psychic that
you hang out with that group that you
hang out with
let's uh have the seance over at julia's
house
and maybe that whole that'll like freak
her out because she's still upset about
the daughter dying so it's like maybe
that'll freak her out she'll be scared
and she'll want to come back to me
because
she won't want to live by herself
anymore in that creepy old house
so basically the sister calls up and is
like uh
hey can we have like a psychic meeting
over your house tonight okay thanks you
know what i mean so julia's like um
i guess so all right so i've seen some
other reviewers say that julia
organized the the seance but that's not
correct the seance actually got sort of
foisted upon her i forgot to mention too
that
all along this time period like even
before the seance happens
she's been you know when she's been
walking around she keeps seeing
what she thinks is her daughter not
necessarily a ghost but like she'd see
like a girl like at the school and like
see the back of her head and it kind of
looked like her and she kind of saw her
like leaning in the park like playing in
the sandbox and stuff
but then like she'd disappear so she
does kind of think that maybe there is
something going on
so during this seance which she and she
does not want to participate in and she
has mark come over too it'll kind of be
you know moral support or whatever and
she doesn't want to participate but the
other people are participating
and the psychic who is there doesn't get
too far into the ship before she starts
like wigging out
like she's just kind of like no it's not
safe here it's not safe she's like
saying [ __ ] like that
and then another woman in the group goes
upstairs to the bathroom
and something apparently frightens her
and she falls down the stairs like she's
not hurt that badly
but she kind of won't say what it was
that scared her and then julia starts
saying to the psychic she's like what
the [ __ ]
what did you see like what upset you so
much because they had to cut the seance
short
and all she'll say is like i saw a child
i saw a child so of course julia thinks
that you know that she's seeing her
daughter katie
but the psychic also says you can't stay
in that house it's not
safe there and julia's sitting there
going well if my daughter was like
haunting the house was like hanging
around why would that make it unsafe
so as the time goes on like i said
magnus is still creeping around he's
kind of like trying to bust into the
house and all this other kind of crap
now what ends up happening too is that
there's a scene where
julia goes to the park sees what she
thinks is her daughter
then she disappears and then she goes
over there to where
the the little girl was digging in the
sandbox and she finds like a pet turtle
and it's like all cut up and then she
finds a knife
that looks pretty much like the knife
like a scalpel type knife that she used
to do the tracheotomy on her daughter
so there's that kind of creepy [ __ ]
magnus breaks into her house while she's
not there
and he thinks she's home because he
hears something he sees the heater on
um you know and he thinks he hears
something down in the basement
but something apparently pushes him down
the basement stairs and he dies
now nobody ever finds the body which i'm
going to get back to in a minute because
that kind of goes into a theory that i
have about
about what's going on in this movie and
then as the story goes on
julia becomes determined to figure out
what the [ __ ] is going on
in this house so she finds out a few
things she goes back to the psychic the
psychic says
i didn't see you know i said a child i
didn't say it was a little girl it's
actually a little boy
and all she said was you know the little
boy he's in the park and he's all
bleeding so julia finds out
that a little boy named jeffrey braden
was murdered
in the same park that she had seen the
cut-up turtle and he was murdered about
30 years ago
because he was he used to get like
bullied and picked on because he was a
german
and she finds out she goes to see the
got the kids uh
mom and the kid's mom is basically like
well
this uh vagrant that used to kind of
hang around the park
was actually arrested and executed for
his murder but i know he didn't do it
it's like it was actually all these kids
that used to pick on him
and she's like and a couple of them are
still alive and so she gives julia their
names
so as julia is undergoing this
investigation
it turns out what happened was that the
little boy that was murdered
it was actually a bunch of kids that had
been picking on him and the ringleader
of the kids was this little girl
named olivia rudge who used to live with
her mom
in the house that julia is now living in
olivia rudge
uh apparently died the same way that
julia's daughter died or at least that's
what you're
led to believe at first like the
neighbor is like yes you know the little
girl that used to live here like she
choked to death
in this house so julia begins to
twig on to the fact that it is actually
not her daughter
katie that is haunting her but it's this
little girl
olivia who is actually a murderer
so she basically she goes to see
olivia's mother who is still alive and
she's and she's super old but she's like
in a
mental hospital or something like that
and the old woman is like totally crazy
but she somehow knows that julia quote
unquote killed her daughter
which julia's like yeah i didn't kill
her but i mean she that's the thing it's
like she didn't really kill or kill her
yes she did do the tracheotomy but the
little girl probably would have died
anyway because i don't think that the
i mean she was already looked like she
was turning blue and stuff like before
the
ambulance people even got there so i
don't think she was necessarily
responsible for the death because
you know katie would have died anyway
but the old lady like screams that are
you killed your daughter too and she's
like i also killed my daughter because
she was evil incarnate so i just
strangled the little brat
uh you know and i guess that olivia's
mom knew that
she had killed that little boy and the
thing about it too is that she not only
killed the little kid she had she had
this kind of like
um sort of power over the other kids she
could like make them do [ __ ]
and apparently she made them kill
animals and then when they killed
jeffrey braden it's like she not only
smothered the kid but then
she like cut his penis off so she was a
pretty horrible child
so her mom ended up killing her so julia
finds all this [ __ ] out like i said
you know her husband magnus is dead in
the basement she never finds the body
her friend mark
also gets killed and it's kind of weird
because there's a scene
where mark was supposed to go with her
to
go see um heather rudge who was olivia's
mother
like in the asylum and he never shows up
but she goes anyway
now prior to this you see a scene where
julia is unplugging
the heater in her house remember i said
the heater that doesn't that never goes
off
and she like unplugs the heater and like
sparks fly out of it and then at the
same time you're led to believe
mark is in the bathtub and a lamp falls
into the bathtub and electrocutes him
and then they show a scene like where
she's kind of sitting on the stairs
like she's gonna go see the the woman or
whatever and then like
he there's a cutaway he dies in the
bathtub and then you go back and her
she's gone like she's not sitting on the
stairs anymore so
when you get to the thing so at the very
end julia goes back to her house
and she sees the ghost of olivia rudge
who is this
she's a gorgeous little girl she's like
this beautiful little girl these big
huge blue eyes she looks like a china
doll or whatever
and um she's kind of like coming at her
and julia is like accepting it's like
yeah you know
it's all okay now and she's like trying
to embrace her or whatever
and then they kind of like cut away
again and then you see that julia has
either cut her own throat
or the ghost has done it now i've seen
i watched like several reviews of this
earlier and i
feel like some people this is one of
those movies that you really it's kind
of a complicated story
it helps if you've read the novel the
novel is actually um very good
it came out in 1975 it was written by
peter straub as i said
it was actually his first supernatural
novel i think he had just done kind of
like
drama type novels before that but this
was like his first one that was like a
ghost story
and it's really good it has a lot in
common with
um his later book ghost which is just
called ghost story
um but it's not as sprawling as that
it's kind of more like an intimate story
but this is one of those movies where
you really really have to pay attention
to what everybody
is saying otherwise you might not know
what's going on because like i said
it's not a super complicated story but
it is a little bit
complicated so you do kind of have to
listen to all the clues and everything
and there's another thing too that i
think maybe
maybe gets interpreted as like plot
holes but
i have a theory about it that i think
explains all the plot holes
so remember how he said that magnus
breaks into the house like a douche
and ends up falling down the stairs and
dying or someone pushes him down the
stairs you don't see who it is
and then mark ends up dying in the tub
and various other things like that
happen and you're led to believe that
the ghost of this evil little girl
olivia has been doing all this stuff
it's ambiguous enough to leave another
interpretation
it could be too that julia is doing it
and she's cut and you're kind of like
interpreting it that way
but i think the more likely explanation
and this goes back to something that the
psychic whose name was mrs flood if i
didn't mention it
something that the psychic said very
very early on in the movie like right
before they were going to do the seance
at julia's house mrs flood says
that ghosts can only operate through a
living
person so i think the thrust of the
story is that
olivia the ghost if she existed
essentially was possessing
julia so i think julia actually was
going around
you know killing her husband i think she
did like push him down the stairs
she probably killed her friend mark as
well you know i think she was doing all
this stuff
which would explain why you know she
never called mark to see where
where he was why he wasn't turning up
when they were supposed to why she never
found
her husband's body in the basement or
whatever i think the ghost was possessed
was possessing her to do these things
because the ghost of the kid was evil
that so like i said it's not plot holes
it it totally does make sense
anyway what i was saying i really really
really love this movie and i feel like
more people need to see it
as i said if you're really into like i
am
into like these 70s ghost movies
you know 70s haunted house movies this
is a good
this and the changeling are kind of
similar i know the changeling came out a
couple years after this
1980 because like i said this came out
in 1977 at least in the uk
it didn't come out in the us until 1981
but
this and the changeling are a similar
kind of vibe i think the changeling had
like a bigger budget
but you know it's along the same lines
it's along the same
tone has to do with uh you know grief
and like
you know a family being killed and then
you know then the ghost of someone else
haunting someone and then
you know you having to solve a murder
mystery like in your new house so it is
a
similar kind of thing also you know like
i said it's a little bit like
rosemary's baby because mia farrow's
character is
kind of like the character she played in
rosemary's baby as well
and you know just that kind of stuff
burnt offerings as i mentioned before
just so if you like anything like that
it's a very slow burn
it's very um creepy it's really
atmospheric
like i said the music i just love love
love the music in this movie i just i
don't know what it is it's just it's
really
it really like it's very evocative and
it just really kind of like takes me
somewhere
and i'm really into it if this is sounds
like something that you would be into
then definitely check it out because i
feel like it's really really
underappreciated really underrated you
can watch it for free on youtube
however if you have shutter you can see
it on there which probably would look a
lot nicer
and as i don't know if you can buy it in
physical medium i don't
you know whether that matters to you or
not i think you can rent it on youtube
now as well so like i said maybe it has
been restored
which i think is really cool because i
don't know it just
i feel like it got released back back
then and it just kind of went nowhere
and i didn't even you know even a horror
junkie like me i had never
heard of it and even though i really
liked peter straub but i really liked
the adaptation the movie adaptation they
did of uh ghost story which is in 1981
and so i was like really surprised that
i had never heard of this one and i just
kind of stumbled across it accidentally
one day
and i was like where the hell is this
movie been all my life you know what i
mean
and i just feel like it's it's just
really not well known and that's kind of
a shame
because i really dig it but yeah so if
you get a chance
please check it out it's really good
like i said the haunting of julia's
what's called the novel
is just called julia i've also seen it
called full circle so
you know maybe you can be able to find
it under that if you're in another
country
and that will do it for this flickers of
fear i will see you guys
on the next one bye